fans of The CW's Batwoman will be
disappointed to learn that Ruby Rose is
unexpectedly bowed out of the title role
of Kate Kane departing from the show
appears to be perfectly amicable as
Rose's announcement includes a long
thank you to her director and producers
for the opportunity nonetheless she
seems to feel walking away is best for
her future it's not as though the show
has performed poorly that woman's
premiere season punched in a comparable
weight class to more established shows
in the cable networks arrowverse lineup
ending up as the network's third
most-watched programme of 2019 the news
of the lead actors departure is
surprising and even upsetting but it's
not all bad with the recent announcement
from the CW that the network plans to
delay virtually all new season premieres
until at least January 2021
that woman's producers will have plenty
of extra time to seek out a new lead
lending further comfort the press
release confirming Rose's departure
additionally included a reassurance that
the channel is still dedicated to
finding another LGBTQ actress to fill
the role of the canonically lesbian hero
but why did Ruby Rose exit the role so
suddenly when everything seems to be
going just the way any television actor
would want well there are a number of
possible reasons back in the summer of
2019 Rose had to have emergency surgery
due to herniated discs in her spine to
threaten to paralyze her
this is just fine you'd see two of your
disks if any aided and they've broken
all the protective layers you have like
this tiny amount that your spine is like
not severed the injury was sustained at
some point during the filming of that
woman's first season and over time as
Rose began to experience numbness in her
extremities realization set in that the
injury might be much more serious than a
first believed she didn't reveal this
fact until that September well after the
surgery and as far as anyone is publicly
aware she has indeed recovered just fine
from her injury variety reports an
anonymous source that claims Rose
departing the role has nothing to do
with her health but it's difficult to
say exactly what that means she's
probably perfectly healthy now since
doctors intervened before the injury
could become permanent but it may have
affected her strength and flexibility in
a way that prevented her from fully
recovering
time for filming it's not necessarily
that she's unhealthy but there could be
uncertainty around how safe it is to
continue performing such a stunt heavy
roll after a spine injury even a healed
one it's also entirely possible that the
injury has simply brought rose to
second-guess her dedication to the role
any one would question how willing they
are to continue working a job after
getting so seriously hurt on-site even
when there's no one at fault
the affer mentioned network-wide delay
of new content on the CW alternatively
may have provided rows and opportunities
she may have been looking for in an
interview with glamour in September 2019
shortly before the revelation of her
spinal injury Rose confessed to feeling
homesick for her native Australia and
that she had an interest in pursuing
future roles closer to home television
work in America necessitates keeping a
part-time home in LA and living there at
least during the filming season though
it's beneficial to remain during all the
required press tours as well when you
consider that TV pre-production and
filming can take up almost half the year
on its own and that Australia is
thousands of miles away it would be
extraordinarily difficult to spend much
time back in Australia while playing a
principal role in a sprawling superhero
television franchise like the air overs
she has also been open about past
struggles with her mental health so it's
understandable that being closer to home
might help her feel more grounded
whatever the reason for Rosa's departure
she's entirely allowed to walk away
especially in circumstances so
unprecedented that a whole television
network has shifted its release schedule
Rose has no publicly announced project
that she's gravitating towards instead
not that she would need to have one to
justify her decision wherever she shows
up next we'll certainly be excited to
see her again I will protect my
no you won't cause you're done get out
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]